a showgirl costume right thank you very
much but that's not gonna happen
happy tuesday everybody it is gonna be
another hot one yeah we started the week
out at 107 degrees yesterday gorgeous
skies
that's the mid-level clouds just kind of
floating through right now but really
it's pretty clear
temperatures are warm too we're in the
80s and
we've only dried out just a skosh since
yesterday
nothing to really sweep out all that
moisture 70s out at red rock this
morning as well as
indian springs and the parrot valley
from checking in at 77 right now 80 in
sandy valley 90 in laughlin
87 in boulder city mesquite you're
looking at heat warnings that take
effect today as well as out at lake mead
if you're going to head out to the lake
and get some cool air on the water out
there just know you got to take lots of
sunscreen and water with you
because we've got more heat coming today
heat warnings
and getting hotter and drier for the
next several days
we'll look for heat warnings today
through thursday for southern nevada
near record highs so by wednesday and
thursday
so for the lake the river northwest
arizona northeast clark county today
we're looking at temperatures between
110 to 115 today through thursday
heat warnings take effect at 10 a.m and
then for central clark county including
the las vegas valley
western clark county including indian
springs and over into southern nye
county including perum
those heat warnings start tomorrow
morning 10 a.m until thursday night at 8
o'clock
temps anywhere between 109 to 114
a lot of heat and we will have a drier
influence tomorrow we'll get some more
southwesterly breezes
that will help give us even drier air we
need it when we get that hot
it can't be sticky too because it's just
such oppressive heat at that point
109 today we're going up to 111 both
wednesday thursday
really close to record highs then and
then temperatures
just barely back off to finish the week
at 107
more seasonal norms by sunday and monday
thank goodness no storms in the forecast
so we'll keep it that way for now